what we're going to do in this video is
dig a little bit deeper into the notion
of democracy and the reason why this is
going to be valuable is it's going to
inform the decisions that the founding
fathers had to make when they thought
about whether to ratify the constitution
it'll also inform our thoughts on
government as it is today in the united
states what flavor of democracy does it
take on especially at different layers
of government
so just as a review and this is
something that we have talked about in
other videos democracy comes from greek
for from rule by the people demo from
demos which is referring to people
and crassy coming from crotea which is
referring to rule so rule by the people
now broadly speaking we can think of
three general flavors of democracy
the first we can consider to be
participatory
participatory democracy
the second
we can call
pluralist
democracy
and i'll define these in a second and
then the third let's call that elite
democracy
elite democracy
now what do you think participatory
democracy means based on the word
participatory
yes as you might have guessed it implies
broad participation of the population
broad participation what are examples of
a participatory democracy well imagine a
small town
that has maybe a few hundred or a few
thousand people
and if there's an issue of whether to
build a stoplight at an intersection or
change some of the zoning laws you can
imagine a large chunk of the town
showing up to weigh in on that decision
now what are some of the benefits of a
participatory democracy and what are
some of the the negatives
well the benefits are and i'll do those
as pluses a benefit is well it kind of
seems closest to the original spirit of
a democracy it's coming out of ancient
greece ancient athens the birthplace of
democracy where you did have residents
go together and debate the major issues
although even in ancient athens you have
to take participation with a grain of
salt because it wasn't everyone who was
participating it was for the most part
wealthy men who had the time to actually
sit and debate these issues
but if we want to give a participatory
democracy its credit say in a small town
is that you really are representing the
views of the people
representing
the people
well
the people are directly involved
now what are maybe some of the negatives
well it can get logistically difficult
we talked about a small town
but what if the town gets a little bit
bigger or what if we're dealing with a
state or we're dealing with a country
where we're talking about
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands or millions or tens of
millions of people how do you get all of
those people to weigh in on an issue
even logistically how do they get
informed about it and are they even
prepared to be to weigh in on those
issues sure if you're in a town you can
think about whether an intersection
should be there or whether they should
put a stoplight there but if we're
talking about matters of national or
international importance influencing
hundreds of millions of people can you
depend on people to be informed about
the intricacies of the banking system or
the military or foreign policy and so
this is really a question of does this
scale
and there really aren't any good
examples in history of direct democracy
scaling in significant ways beyond
fairly small groups of people in the
united states the biggest scale where
you might see this are in things like
ballot measures at the city or the state
level where people are directly voting
on certain measures or certain laws but
even there it's a limited scope for what
the people will actually weigh in on
now the next category that we talk about
is a pluralist democracy pluralism is
referring to the idea of many different
parties same root as the word plural you
have many things
so you have
many different parties and many
different competing interests that are
going to have a
vigorous debate with each other on
deciding what are the best ideas and
what are examples of pluralist
democracies if you think about the
united states there are many different
interest groups you could think about
all the different lobbyists all of the
different groups that represent
different types of people trying to
convince members of congress either at
the national level or even at the state
level that their interest is right even
within congress even though you have two
major parties you can have different
factions that are really trying to argue
it out
now what are the benefits of a pluralist
democracy
well you can imagine that because
there's this vigorous debate maybe the
good ideas surface
good
ideas
surface
you don't have domination by just one
party
no
one group
one
group or a small group of people
domination
but then on the other side of it maybe
there are some negatives what what might
those be
well maybe all of this debate and
argument is very inefficient maybe it
takes a maybe it's slow decision making
slow
decisions or to extreme no decisions
some things like gridlock because people
can't agree to things that in order for
anything to get done you have to make
too many people happy and they all have
their interests maybe the opposite of
good idea surface maybe good ideas die
because it's very hard to make everyone
happy
now the last category that we're going
to talk about is the idea of an elite
democracy and this is where you have
more limited participation so in some
ways it's almost the opposite of a
participatory democracy so this is
limited
participation
and even though i gave ancient athens as
an example of a participatory democracy
it really was more of an elite democracy
where the people had the time and the
influence and the money those were the
ones who were really weighing in on the
issues of ancient athens
and if you were to go to the roman
republic the roman senators these were
once again elite men so what would you
think are benefits of an elite democracy
well one might be that these elites so
to speak maybe they are more educated
than the general public
and so that allows them to make more
informed decisions
especially on things that are quite
complex that would be hard for everyone
to weigh in on if or you're going to
change a new accounting standard or
think about how do you how do you
regulate the telecommunications industry
or some very sophisticated trade
negotiation or foreign policy
negotiation that education might help
and maybe it's also more
decisive
than either one of the pluralist or the
participatory the participatory they
might be able to appeal to maybe baser
instincts just you know people's
passions while the pluralists since you
have all of these groups competing even
if something makes sense they might not
be able to make that decision but if you
have a smaller more limited group
limited participation maybe they can
make these decisions a little bit
clearer
but what are the negatives here
well the neg the clearest negative is
well maybe this goes against the whole
idea of a democracy if it's all about
the elites maybe they do a good job at
truly representing the interests of the
people
but maybe they are good at representing
the interests of the elite so do they
really
represent
represent the people
is this a democracy where the people are
sovereign where the people rule or is
this an oligarchy where only a few
people rule and they rule in their own
interests
and so after watching this video look at
the world around you think about in the
united states or whatever country you
are watching from what elements of a
participatory democracy do you see what
elements of a pluralist democracy and
what elements of an elite democracy do
you see
and as we'll see in other videos these
dimensions of democracy were vigorously
debated by the founding fathers when
they thought about whether to ratify the
constitution
we'll see this debate when we look at
the anti-federalist papers especially
we'll look closely at brutus number one
we'll see this debate when we look at
the federalist papers especially
federalist number 10 written by james
madison and i'll let you decide when we
look at that who was right and what
flavors of democracy are most dominant
in the united states at different levels